DANIEL FRIEDMAN: All right.
Welcome to
active live stream number 50.0.
It is October 17th, 2022,
and we are starting the series
on “Interoception
as modeling, Allostasis as control.”
Welcome to the Active Inference
Institute.
We're a participatory online institute
that is communicating,
learning and practicing
applied active inference.
This is recorded
and an archived livestream,
so please provide us with feedback
so we can improve our work.
All backgrounds
and perspectives are welcome
and we'll be following
video etiquette for livestreams.
Today in 50.0.
We're starting this series
discussing the paper “Interoception
as modeling, Allostasis as control”
The authors are Eli
Sennesh, Jordan Theriault,
Dana Brooks,  Jan-Willem van de
Meent,
Lisa Feldman Barrett,
and Karen S Quigley.
It is a paper
published
in the journal Biological Psychology
in January of 2022.
And this is just an introduction
and context video as Dean here and I
work through this
paper and discuss some related topics.
We're going to
go over some big questions.
Basic aims and abstract
roadmap of the paper.
Then go into the paper,
touch on a few key points
and images and themes.
And then primarily
look forward
to discussing it
with any authors
or anyone else
who'd like to join in the coming weeks.
All right.
So I'm Daniel.
I'm a researcher in California,
and the paper was selected
by decentralized upvote.
It was fun to read
and it brings some new topics
into our regime of attention.
So I'm looking forward to this
and I'll pass to Dean.
>>>DEAN: Actually, I'm. I'm Dean.
I'm here in Calgary.
I think what's interesting about
any paper
that calls to seemingly discrete
things and put some proximal and
gets them entangling
and then pulls them apart again
and tries to look at
sort of what
happens when things get combined
is always
something that I'm always
interested in that
in fact it is the title of this
and the fact
that they were bringing out a Stacy's
intersection together.
And what does that mean?
Was the reason why
I spent a lot of time on this.
And really,
I'm quite interested in hearing
what the authors have to say
now that they put this idea to
to work.
All right.
How would you describe the big question?
Well, I mean,
I think the focus here is on
on what happens
and what we can say about
control requires
necessary to carry out
physiological tasks, varying
degrees of complexity.
I've never been really sure
how the specificity
of different outcomes and behaviors
looks in aggregate,
but I think one of the things that
we can say is
if there is a predictive component
and there's a feedback component,
and they're focusing on two particular
types of that,
it's interesting, perhaps
what kind of generalities
we can walk away with
never,
you know, sort of
not getting lost in the weeds
of, well, this happened here
and then that happened there.
But just on that general level,
what what sorts of things,
when those two things are put together,
should we say has
a certain pattern or commonality?
Nice. I agree.
I would put it in the category
of asking
how a given system, independent
or modality independent phenomena
like our status,
which is anticipatory changes
in physiology,
connects with a domain or a use case
like interception.
And it does
seem like a lot of the models
that we've explored have been visual
or conceptual or symbolic,
and the intercept of modality
has popped up again and again
in discussions.
And so this is a cool opportunity to
look at some formalism for intersection.
Okay, here's the paper
as described earlier,
just a few of the highlights
that were written
by the authors on the publication page.
Interception enables
the brain
to anticipate the body's
upcoming metabolic needs.
Interception provides
performance metrics
for visceral motor regulation.
We connect
control theory
with decision
making and motor control of the body.
We model our static control
as optimal control
with the time varying reference signal.
They talk about some
limitations of previous models
and some unique aspects of what
their model does
and the way that they formulate
the APC model.
Anything to add?
Well,
I think their answer is straightforward.
Okay. On claims.
So Dean and I were looking into.
Just.
Thinking of ourselves
in terms of claims
adjusters, appraisers, examiners
and investigators
as we
pulled out a whole handful
of really important and salient
within the arguments of this
relatively long
and technically scaffolded paper
and pulling out a bunch of claims
that are written that connect the dots
and set some of the relevant
interpretations for the formalism.
Do you want to highlight any of them or.
It's fine to just have them
for anyone who wants to.
Yeah, I'm not going to
I'm not going to read of this.
But I will say this here.
There is a
I think a parallel
trying to be drawn here between
predictive or predictive processing.
I'm not saying
that predictive processing,
but processing as a
as a predictive device and feelings
and control and feedback.
And so I think
there are a lot of claims
that can be made.
But that's a really, really nuanced and
also a very, very complex
space to play in.
And so I can understand why
there's lots and lots of claims.
Again, whether or not or how far
those claims can hold
before they break down
will be an interesting
thing to talk to with the authors.
Yeah, well said.
It's a very intertwined area.
Maybe that's what you're
pointing towards when you say
complex braiding.
Yeah, I. Mean, a lot of hair.
So it's it's tricky for me.
All right.
Abstract.
Okay.
I'll read the first three.
The brain regulates the body
by anticipating its needs and attempting
to meet them before they arise.
A process called Alices
Alice Stages requires
a model of the changing sensory
conditions within the body,
a process called interception.
In this paper,
we examined how interception
may provide
performance feedback for Alice stresses.
We suggest
studying ALICE status
in terms of control theory,
reviewing control
theories, applications to related issues
in physiology, motor control and
decision making.
We synthesize these by relating them
to the important properties of ALICE
static regulation as a control problem.
We then sketch a novel formalism
for how the brain
might performing
a static control of the viscera
by analogy to scales or motor control,
including a mathematical view
of intercept, acts
as a performance feedback
for Alice thesis.
Finally, we suggest ways
to test implications of our hypothesis.
Onto the roadmap.
The paper starts with introduction.
The function
of the brain in the body
and then introduces some of the key
pillars or foundations of their
synthesis and interpretation,
which is intersection
control theory as an approach
for unifying physiology,
motor control, decision making.
And Alice stresses as a trajectory
tracking stochastic optimal control.
The fifth section is a discussion
and then there's an appendix B and C
and in their words, four sections
in this paper
connected to the reception
to ALICE Status.
Section two establishes
how interception enables the brain
to estimate
the physiological efficiency of the body
in the present moment,
which is precisely what it needs
to know to evaluate and refine action.
Section three Introduces Control Theory.
Section four applies
the principles of Control Theory
to derive a novel format model
of how the brain
might estimate
the desirability
of physiological trajectories
and make prospective
regulatory decisions.
Finally, Section five synthesizes
the previous three sections
to explore the direct implications
of the proposed formalism.
Appendix eight provides
a glossary of terms,
but this is moved up
and it's no longer an appendix.
So there's no appendix de.
Appendix B one provides
mathematical details
related to Section three, and Appendix
C one provides mathematical details
related to Section four.
The keywords were
interception
analysis and predictive processing.
We're going to talk
a lot about interception and our status
somewhat in this thought zero,
but certainly in the coming discussions
and for predictive processing
a good recent stream is live
stream number 43 with Maria.
Okay.
Also just for reference,
will pause on these
just long enough for you
to screenshot them if you want.
There's a nomenclature table
with the definition of many words.
So here's the first nomenclature terms
one through 25,
and then here's the second
half of the normal feature, 26 to 49
sorted alphabetically.
Anything to add on the nomenclature
other than to say that
it's good that they provided it
and it will be
used in the coming sections?
Well, I think it's interesting
that you pointed out that the they
they pulled the definitions forward.
And then you look at the formulas.
And so I think from the standpoint
of what they want,
they want a message around this
is braiding
requires us to at least
get a common sense around
what things mean before we start
trying to pull apart what they equal.
So yeah, I kind of kind of like that.
Well said.
All right.
Section one,
introduction
the functions of the brain in the body.
Okay.
There's an evocative beginning
to this paper.
Playing a simple game of dodgeball,
then requires your brain
to continually coordinate
the systems of your body.
And this motif of dodgeball
is going to be returning again.
And on the left is a hugging face
implement tation of a stable
diffusion algorithm.
The prompt of the image was dodgeball,
playful ants,
active inference, free energy principle.
And while we were making the slides,
we were engaged in active inference
with some of these image generating
affordances and allowing that to
do what?
Well, I think
it's really interesting that this
what the what the generator said
this would be the result
of a coordinated
what's the word I'm looking for
entanglement of these are these prompts
to generate how can you think about what
what strategy
each one of those
silhouettes is now employed?
And I think that
there is an implied sense
that there's a strategy going on
as well.
So, again, when you bring some of these
really interesting things together,
I guess it depends on how deep
you want to go,
how much you want
to dimensionalize the space.
So what is that right there?
Yeah, this is the same prompt.
This was just another one.
This one's a little more photorealistic,
a little bit more like
elusive, you know?
Are they playing dodgeball?
Yeah.
Or are they adjusting for.
All right,
next keyword,
you can go for it
if you just
people can read the definition here,
but just give your own take.
What is interception?
Well, I think the thought that
at the end of the day,
there's there's a certain
amount of
signaling
signaling going on
that we become aware of.
Sometimes young people
or all people might
sort of categorize them all
under the umbrella of feelings.
And
I've got this from tots on target
just because I always worked
in that kind of space of
how do we keep this as simple as we can?
And so when you get these signals,
these sensory signals
originate from within the body,
these are the feelings you get.
And
whether or not you connect
them to the world outside of your skin
or your margins,
sometimes you do, sometimes you don't.
You just wake up with a tummy ache.
Right.
So what does that mean about today?
Ice,
I would say a little narrowly
interception is referring to some
observation and inference
on hidden states
with a referent that's inteiro
inside of the body
as opposed to zero outside of the body.
But there's probably
also a lot of like blurring.
And what is the retina really doing?
Is it doing inference on itself
and where is it actually doing inference
on the outside world structure?
Right. Intercept of internal models.
You added some images. So what are they?
Yeah.
So I'll just read this real quick.
Psychologists
refer to the trend of thought,
including interception by many terms.
I think I think that's important
because there hasn't
always been agreement
about clearly defining what
an internal model is
thinks like unconscious inference
seems to fit into this realm of embodied
simulation concepts and categories.
Controlled hallucination,
which was new to me
because I don't know what
that even means.
And regardless of what it's called,
the author says to construct
a dynamic model of its body
in the world in shape,
we use the terms prediction,
simulation, concept.
And so for somebody with sort of my deep
research background
in terms of abduction to signal
interpreted the object,
what is that model of how do we
how do we avoid getting into another
great debate
about whether that's
representational and content
filled or not?
Or is there something that
we sense from the inside every day,
every single time
data is coming at us and being poured
onto our different sensory surfaces,
exterior, external from the outside,
I think that there's a
piece that comes from the outside.
I know when the temperature
goes up in the room,
but my temperature
might also be going up
because a too bad shrimp
and it's sometimes difficult
to figure out whether or not it's
because the heat gone up
or whether my body's
responding with an inflammatory
gesture.
Yeah, that's a
nice point.
Like sometimes called difference
making cause or difference
that makes a difference.
Does a viral infection
cause the body temperature to rise
and or to what extent cannot
be decomposed
into factors from the virus versus
the dynamics
changing of the immune system.
So in
the image on the left nose, I can know,
I can't tell
whether the image on the left
by the image on the left,
what's what speed
the image on the right
is actually moving down the road.
And that's kind of why I wanted the
ambiguity there
for an intercepted model because,
you know, Damasio talks a lot about like
what can we really describe in perceived
precise terms
and what remains somewhat ambiguous.
And the authors in this paper
talk a little bit about that as well.
Yeah,
when the referent is external,
it's objective.
Then there's the opportunity
for multiple
external perspectives to align.
Not even saying that's better,
but just the opportunity to do more.
As if the embodied behavior
of your physiological set point for some
physiological regulation is changed.
It doesn't have the same opportunity
for external alignment.
Again, for better
and for worse, and almost always
with difficulty communicating
or sometimes measuring in laboratory
settings as well
and can quote, controlling.
So speaking with authors on this and
why they study this modality
will be interesting.
Yeah. All right.
As for the computational or
system independent phenomena
that they're going
to be trying to integrate with,
our with an interception is our status.
They define this term as alpha
status is to anticipate
changing needs, evaluate priorities
and prepare the organism
to satisfy them
before they lead to errors,
a process called alpha status.
So let's just say
that you have an alpha static model
of the temperature in the room
and the core body
temperature doesn't change.
So then
can one look back and say
it didn't change
because it was expected to change?
And somebody will just say, well,
how do you know it worked?
And because it didn't
raise the body temperature.
I focused on the part
that the fact that they describe it
as a three part process.
So me being always talking about
what's the minimum here,
what's the minimum here
that we need in order to be able to
do this?
I find that really,
really quite interesting.
Why three,
not four or five are breaking it out
into into smaller slices.
That's again,
another one of those questions.
I'd like to be able to talk
to the authors about.
All right.
Active inference
they wrote
before
diving into formal modeling details
below
which we're going
to get to later in the paper.
It might be helpful to compare
and contrast the approach here APC
with the prominent modeling framework,
active inference,
and we're going to return to
some of these details
and I'm sure
have a lot of discussion on it.
But you made a really interesting point
in our preparation
about how
they're not treating their model as a
downstream or a corollary of any
commitment to a particular physics,
which is how we often hear
about free energy
principle, basic mechanics,
but rather they're treating
the model as a first order
of construction.
Anything you want to add on that?
Because I thought that was really like,
help me frame what the paper was about.
You know, that street
where I think that the
fourth bullet,
unlike most active as far as the lecture
material below, considers
an indefinite time or infinite horizon.
Control setting
is interesting
because that makes it really,
really clear
between what they're talking about
and what we often see
in a lot of the representations,
which is to 0t12t, whatever,
in terms
of being able to figure out
what is going on sequentially.
So.
Right, cool.
This section in the introduction
talks
about some issues with other models.
They talk about how existing
models of intersection
have either formulated elasticity
as a prospective decision making problem
without considering
how these decisions are enacted,
which has a bunch
of different interpretations,
but maybe, for example,
requiring the enumeration of policies
and then the selection from policies
or as a motor control problem
without considering
where motor commands come from.
Another issue they
have with other models, rather
than treat metabolic efficiency
as the objective,
they discuss homeostasis,
the regulation of bodily
variables to fix set points
with fixed tolerance for error.
So this is
really going to be a cool theme which is
rather than fixed
the set point in variability,
see that outcome
as being due to some other process
that does results in an attracting set
or point
with a fixed set point and an empirical
tolerance for error
as well as maybe
some points of no return and so on.
But seeing all those outcomes
as the realization of a dynamical system
that actually doesn't
pursue a set point, but rather pursues
a slope on a graph that we'll explore,
and that like
zone of maximum control ability
and reduction of surprises around
the zone of maximum controllability
over evolutionary time
will come to be
associated with this
kind of a survival variable
and some other points.
Okay. Anything else?
Well, its relationship,
relationship, relationship.
And then they say this paper
aims to fill this gap.
I think relation doesn't
necessarily imply
that things have to get
closed in terms of
whatever the gap is
by filling something in.
I think I think the fact
that they talk about targeting,
I think
the fact that
they see relationship as playing
kind of the key
role in
what they think is happening here
means that that maybe the gap
continues.
I mean,
they're putting stuff in here
for us to consider and contemplate,
but I'm not sure
if we're actually filling a gap
or if we're just sort of understanding
what's in the space, right.
Section two.
So at the beginning of Section two,
the top
paragraphs,
interception modeling, the body,
estimating insufficiency,
and then the below the fold.
Section 2.5, the summary.
So both of these
pre and post 22.02.2
contains a lot of structural information
about the key points in this paper.
Anything to add on this specific
slide two
or we'll just go on
through the section, just.
A quick
start down at the very bottom there.
People might want to have a read on that
because I think that's
not saying
that that's controversial,
but I do think it's interesting.
Yeah.
That the
the movement towards the responsive
range of a capacity curve
could be potentially
obviating the need
for a dedicated neural circuit or module
that specifically calculates
the behavioral constructs
of reward and cost.
So what does it mean to move into a
non reward centric
understanding of physiology
or reinterpreting reward?
K Section 2.1 introduces a distinction
that is going to be key
in the rest of the paper,
which is the difference
between two types of visceral
sensory variables. Intercept
those which represent
quantities of resources,
regulated resources,
and those which represents rates
which processes
act controlled processes.
Regulated resources are kept stable,
relatively stable over time.
Examples include blood
glucose and core body temperature.
So of note is
they don't have to be a deplete
of all resource.
The regulated resource is kind of
like the bounded
variable in a physiology
in a homeostasis context.
It's not necessarily
a deplete of all like metabolite
regulated resources, like blood glucose
or core body temperature
represents a physical quantity
or substance like glucose.
Its quantity
cannot change instantaneously.
So I think it will be interesting
to ask like
what different
regulatory sources
I of different modalities are
and then controlled processes
are the rates
at which
physiological processes operate.
So in that case would be like
the kind of input
output relationships of blood glucose.
Okay.
Yeah, we just talk about that.
We talked about that
recently is what's the difference
between gripper and grip
and can both exist at once.
Nice
to point
you back to the dodgeball example.
The heart rate
and the blood pressure must increase
during aerobic exercise.
As noted in the dodgeball example.
So there has to be
some physiological adaptation
in order to start
exercising and continue exercising
upon resting conditions.
The barer receptors
that's pressure
receptor heart rate
reflex would normally counter
any rise in blood pressure
by slowing the heartbeat.
However, with exertion,
your blood pressure and heart rate
both must increase to support
the needed increase
in blood flow
required by your exercising muscles.
And so then there's a discussion
of how this kind of modulation of reflex
allows for
the shifting of an entire function
relating a change in blood
pressure to a change in your heart rate.
So this is describing
like a
dynamical systems
approach and physiological model
for how the causal
or correlational structure
of different physiological
variables can be models
pretty generally,
but it's going to get more specific.
Now, a little a little bit of variation
there and
and physiology and where we go.
To point to predicting and modeling
the ranges of regulated
and controlled processes.
This is describing
some of the parameters of the curve,
the threshold and saturation points,
which partly
define curves
that are derived from functions
which physiologists
commonly used to model.
The connection between perturbations
and regulatory responses
usually naming them
response curves or transfer functions.
And then the term capacity curves
will be used to emphasize
the fact that while such curves
can shift over time
in any one instant,
they represent the current range
of limited
regulatory resources
available to an organism.
So one could imagine, like a financial
capacity curve to maintain some
market
at some point,
like kind of like the depth,
but by analogy.
And then this
idea of modeling
how a system responds to perturbations
doesn't necessarily require
modeling the internal model
of that system.
But as you build a better
generative model
of the system, being perturbed,
then the better experiments
and the further you can
have kind of perturbed ability
of the system,
it allows you to approach a system
without a strong hypothesis
about its structure.
The capacity curve in FIG.
two point or in FIG.
one has the mathematical form,
and then Fig.
one is shown alongside
with equation one.
The parameters are defined.
The function Y is
taking in you view K, big R, big B,
and combining those into an equation.
The figure one on the x axis
is showing the blood pressure
and then the y axis is showing
the baseline activation percentage
of the reflects
modulating this physiological variable.
So at 100, which is the target
blood pressure
or sort of
what would be called
the homeostatic set point
because it seems to be an attractor
at that point.
The baseline
activation of the barrel
reflex is happening
when the blood pressure increases,
then the bell reflex
activates up
to two x
thresholding at two x
activation of baseline.
And then as the blood pressure
decreases, the beryl reflex, again
with this sigmoid symmetry decreases.
That's a dynamical model of regulation,
of blood pressure
equations
two, three and four
outline the form of a generative model
a procedure
for probabilistically
predicting observed variables.
In terms of unobserved variables,
the variables listed
are unobserved variables
which are sampled
from an a primary probability
distribution, not dependent on data.
So that's referring to using
generative model
and how these equations constituted.
The proposal here has an unusual feature
the equations for X,
the mean arterial blood pressure
and Y, the bearer reflex activation
as a percentage of baseline.
So figure one x and y
are in
terms of the quantile variable you
the quantile variables
uniformly represents
the relationship
between the blood pressure
and the barrel reflex activation,
irrespective of changes
in the capacity
curves, operating point view and gain k
the quantile depends
only on the functional form
of the capacity curve
and on the parameters.
So we'll unpack that
a little more technically,
but they point to that
as a feature of their model.
Here again is FIG.
one, a little bigger with more space
to discuss later.
And here's Fig.
two, which is the capacity
curve from Fig.
one in blue
with the linear eye's response in orange
around the operating point, the blue
diamond marker.
So
one can see this as the
maximum positive
slope of this sigmoid curve,
and that under the specification
that the reflex
is going to be activated
in a sigmoid away.
Then, depending on
whether one is
in like a curving up part
or a curving down part
or thinks about it
as pursuing the maximum positive slope,
then pursuing that point
and being rewarded by movements
towards maximum maneuverability
and control
would have the equivalent
of pursuing a homeostatic model
where this is like
a fixed point attractor.
So it puts the kind of bottom
of the ball
in this orange line
being maximized in slope
rather than the blue diamond
being reduced in its distance from 100
right.
I think we copied this
section twice.
It was so unusual.
We copied it twice. And
now.
2.3
returned to the dodgeball example
and they're going to widen their scope
beyond just the barrel reflex
blood pressure
to circulating levels of oxygen,
glucose and carbon dioxide.
Next, we focus on blood
glucose as a regulated resource
with glucagon
as the controlled
process, enabling secretion of glucose
into the blood
and insulin
as the control
process, enabling
removal of glucose from the blood.
So the barrel reflex
was like a single volume knob
or a triage nurse
that can lower
or raise the single response.
So if some physiological variable
is high,
it's like it can be like removed.
Glucose regulation
has multiple hormones.
It's going to be like buffers
from two different sides
in a slightly different way,
but using a lot of the same formalism
and logic to introduce
a slightly
different and more complex
physiological system.
Okay.
The section discusses some findings
that blood glucose blood
glucose levels
are not actively defended
at a biologically hard coded set point.
Any more than heart
rate is instead glucagon and insulin.
Two hormones
activity balance each other's effects
to bring the blood glucose
to a point within its settling range,
with glucose entering the blood
after the person ingest food and glucose
then crossing from the blood
into other bodily tissues
to support their function.
Anything to add on this
slide?
Not that specific,
and I'll wait
till to get to the end of section
the section two stuff.
So here is figure three.
They're writing FIG.
three
shows, plots of the resulting functions
of this equation
applied to the insulin case,
which can be interpreted
as capacity curves.
Orange sigmoid is insulin.
The blue sigmoid is glucagon.
They have different hormone levels, a
different x axis,
which is the level of glucose
in the blood.
And so you kind of see
familiar behavior
and glucose is high, then
insulin is at high secretion,
which drives the absorption of glucose.
And when glucose gets low
in this case below
2.5 or three or so, then
glucagon is secreted to
elicit glucose to enter the blood.
Okay?
And so one can imagine
that the glucose level
will be oscillating in this space,
but not exactly set at a set point
with a residual being minimized.
That section 2.4
is where they move from discussing
this kind of a regulatory model
into viable ranges and capacities
could obviate a modular reward system.
Here's an argument
or appeal to neuroanatomy.
There's no single brain site
that specifically encodes
app additive
or aversive reinforcement value.
It is useful to reframe
discrete reward and decision systems
as domain general
or allosteric static control systems.
The domain generality
of intersection provides
further theoretical support for the idea
that we do not need mental modules
or faculty psychology
concepts to understand how
a brain works,
a mathematically sound
and biologically plausible
account of our static control
does not require a modular or separate
reward system
in the central nervous system.
And a bit more on this topic.
Anything to add?
Now let's get to 37.
All right, the rewards of control.
So here
I wanted to highlight
two papers with some nice images
by both papers
involving Tobias NORVILLE.
And these papers are cited in the paper
under discussion,
and they all show
some pretty interesting features.
So just to highlight
some of these graphs, here's movements
within a glucose and temperature space.
So regulation
of multiple physiological variables
here on the bottom left
is the integration
of interception, homeostatic, set point
and motor
commands like related to foraging.
Here is some Bayesian
visualizations with a prior posture
and likelihood.
And about this two way
relationship type of inference
and a forward dynamical model,
the tail of two densities
and then last one.
This is
another body temperature, glucose
modeling approach that
gets to that
notion that we describe as
going to the bottom of the ball
where the shape of this
napkin
could be designed or evolved or selected
so that the marble spends
most of its time in a certain zone.
And this is like
just one other way
to think about
these types of attractor systems
rather than as like traces or so on.
Okay, anything to add?
I think Section two basically confirms
that if you're going to be doing
any kind of predictive performance
that has a element of continuity
to it, that depends on on sort of
recognizable finite limits
and also variability
within whatever those limits are.
And I think that
kind of speaks to the idea that there's
an in a
in a sort of a two factor situation.
There's signaling that looks like this.
And they sort of pointed out
a couple of examples
of the barrel reflex and then
and the glucagon thing and
they also
are trying to avoid
oversimplifying or over
reducing like they
they tried to keep
the complexity of those two examples
retained in terms
of what they were trying to hold up, as
is something that allows us to start
looking at these capacity curves.
All right.
Section three control theory,
the unifying lens for physiology, motor
control and decision making.
And then one of their summaries
of the chapter.
This section
introduces concepts
from engineering control theory,
then reviews its applications
in the life sciences.
These include Physiology Section 3.1
Skeletal Motor
Movement, Section
3.2 and Decision Making Section 3.3.
Section 3.4 will connect
future intercept of states
to present
movements illuminating
what makes our static regulation
more energy efficient
than homeostatic regulation.
The next section for we'll build off
the account of control
used in physiology
to suggest
how interception supports our spaces.
Okay, here, we're not going
to read everything on the slide,
but this is from section 3.1
Control Theory for Physiology.
A reliable
or reliable body built
from unreliable parts.
Anything to add on this note.
People just want to read this.
Yep.
I'll just call out for a controller to
perform well.
It must contain some sort of copy
or mirror of the plant's
expected behavior,
which is referred
to as an internal model.
Control theorists call this
the driven system to plant
and its desired trajectory,
the reference trajectory.
And there's
some interesting discussion
of this kind of
thread of control theory.
Figure four
So Figure four is a functional block
diagram of model based control system.
The plant in Orange is the object
or system whose.
Motion or other behavior is controlled.
The controller purple
send signals controls,
solid block arrows, the change
how the plant moves and signals
the expected outcome predictions
solid yellow arrow to the state
estimate are in yellow and so on.
People can read the rest of it.
For these figures.
Daniel As
we get further down in the slides,
why don't I read
and then you can run the cursor over
the different parts of the model
so people can kind of see real time
how the two things like.
Sounds get will do that
for the future ones.
And this is going to revoke or recall
some of our earlier discussions
in life frame 23 Skillful Performance
and Interaction ISM and Obstructionism
and how to think about motor plants
and so on.
Right to
section 3.2,
moving the body,
the reference control hypothesis.
So the reference control hypothesis,
the citations provided
were to Feldman 2015 and later 2021
and the referent control
hypothesis describes
the skeletal motor system
in terms of a hierarchy of controllers
with higher level
controllers in the brain,
prescribing reference
trajectories to the lower level
reflex is in the spinal cord.
These referent reflexes
then compare the actual length
of the muscle
as signaled
by afferent proprioceptive neurons
to the reference length
sent down by the brain.
It contracts the muscle
to bring the two into agreement.
And so here
is the top part of the table of content
of Feldman's
2015 book
reference Control of Action
and Perception and the Paper of La
Tosh in Physics of Life Review 2021
with some graphics around
this type of approach,
you can start this slide
on the real world.
Okay, well,
I'll just
point out a couple things
the authors say,
because they
do not want to be accused
of sort of overfitting your structure.
Motor control
experiments only limited overlap
with the actual structure
of motor control.
So only limited overlap
experiment on region
behaviors involves an experimenter
described in reaching task
to the participants.
Participants
brain does not function specifically
to follow instructions
from an experimenter,
but rather to regulate their own body.
The actual
organization of the central nervous
system occurs better with an inside out
view of motor function.
Women at the body, either somatic
cell matter
or motor
pathways surge regulation of the body.
For example, in a game of dodgeball, you
if you unexpectedly step on a hard
or shark bark object, you usually don't
purposely impale yourself
who has stepped on it.
So I just want to go through my foot now
because my
my focus is still on
stabilizing my posture.
Rather, you recoil in pain,
you feel that introspectively
and the unplanned disturbance
of any tissue
damage requires
you to make a decision
about what to do next.
Excuse yourself
to nurse your foreplay
through that pain.
I think
the fact that they're trying to limit
what they are saying is the extent
to which the whole piece of this
can be said to apply
is a good thing,
because I think there's
a couple of areas around.
So what is in this relationship
between a command system
or a control system and a demand system?
Where do things like like when your body
is starting
to suffer
from mild hypothermia and, you know,
people know that
that your brain stops
functioning correctly.
How do you differentiate between,
for example,
I'm getting a
slurping headache
and you put the Slurpee down
and stop drinking it
because you know
that that's the effect versus
you have your limbs
which aren't,
you know, frostbitten
at this point early.
Certainly not frostbitten.
Continue to move
so that you don't stop you
you avoid stopping moving altogether,
which which essentially is death.
So here
we've got to wonder whether or not,
without getting into the argument,
of course, it's pretty obvious
if your brain is dead, you're dead.
But if your hands are dead
and you are still alive,
that clear distinction
between a command center consequence
and a demand center consequence.
What does that mean in terms of,
okay, so there's things that happen
that you do automatically
in order
to keep yourself alive
in some of the most critical situations.
And it's not like your your your
your hand has the brain.
And yet it may in just simply
moving around beyond a reflexive thing,
be able to keep you alive long enough
until somebody comes to
your rescue as a as a, for example.
So I don't know
if that's confusing or not,
but I think that there's
a reconciliation
that goes on between command and demand.
And maybe some of control
is the ability to give up
command at times in order for a new
a new response to take over
and keep you alive.
And you may not necessarily
know how to do that from
a command center.
So we'll have to talk
to the authors about that,
because these are questions that I have,
because I got a bit
of a physiological difference.
I wonder about these extreme situations.
All right.
Section 33, making decisions,
constructing future
reference trajectories.
They use the word demands, so
we'll talk about it later. Yep.
More quotes from 33
for those who want to screenshot
talking about Erica, the city,
which is also raised in the Appendix
B, which we're not going to focus on.
Okay.
You can read figure five
and I'll use the mouse for it.
So a functional block diagram
for an experiment.
Experimental psychologist, task
oriented view of motor control.
The diagram shows a formal logic
structure here at a conceptual up,
the boxes and arrows
do not map onto the anatomy
of a brain or nervous system.
In contrast
to figure for this dagger diagram
differentiates between
skeletal motor brain and peripheral
stretch reflex controllers
between sensory state, estimated
ears, brain
and peripheral sense
organs, sensory surfaces,
sensory surfaces,
the diagram shows
an engineering perspective.
Important to note
that on a psychology experiment
in which the experimenter prescribes
a task for behavior to participants,
so there's an externality
and a participants brain
then access control system to achieve
the behave the prescribed
behavior
systems that maintain the body,
therefore serve systems
that move the body,
which
in turn serve a prescribed behavior.
So again, the focus on the prescriptive,
the externality,
the information coming in.
All right.
Thanks a lot.
Next, one functional block
diagram for a control theoretic view
about Stacy's.
In contrast to Figure five,
this diagram shows a closed loop
control system designed
for the autonomous regulation
of the body
and experimenters
desired task behavior is replaced with
or by sorry,
the other static capacity estimate,
which sends
predictions of capacity curves
which we've already looked at
to the intercept of state estimated
and receives
prediction errors
with reached updated estimates.
The updated estimates are issued
as a reference signal
to the disorder motor controller.
This diagram shows
a formal logical structure,
a conceptual loop.
The hypothesis depicted is constrained
by the inferred
anatomical structures in Bert 2017,
but the boxes and arrows do not map.
I repeat, do not map 1 to 1
part of the anatomy of
the brain or nervous system.
All right, great.
So just to
highlight the difference here,
the left
is almost like an instructional list
arrangement.
And this is
how the experimental psychologist
thinks about this task,
which is like
we write down
the instructions,
the pseudocode for the task,
keep your heart rate within this range.
And then
there's some decision
making with the skeletal motor system.
But they're capable of conscious action
and stretching or more subconscious
and then acting through physiology
in the body or in the external world.
That intercept of state estimated here
comes into alignment with the desire
and implementation
of the skeletal motor decision.
In contrast,
the role of the task instructions,
so to speak, is substituted
in this control theoretic view
with the
our static capacity estimate
or as the imperative,
and that feeds on through a very similar
set on the right side.
But here
we actually have the visceral motor
decision controller
in in contrast to a skeleton motor
because this is more focused on like
choose the left button
or the right button
and figure six
is focused
more on the kind of barrel reflex
control theory view.
But that also generalizes beyond.
Okay,
I think that's just another review
section for Alice
thesis as trajectory
tracking stochastic optimal control.
This section will describe
our formal model of allosteric decision
making the
static path integral control APC model
APC has a simple idea at its core,
just as perceptual concept service
internal models of the body's
sensory surfaces.
Action concepts
also serve
as internal models
of potential behaviors
and their predicted outcomes.
Section 4.1
Drives in SLC
objective function
from the mathematical form
by which section
two representative capacity curves.
Then Section
4.2, 4.3 and 4.4 are described out.
This APC model, anything to add?
Oh, let's go there.
All right.
4.1 Transforming
capacity curves
into objective functions.
Since any given capacity curve,
such as the one in FIG.
one above,
which is a maximum value
on the vertical axis,
it can be divided by its maximum y value
to normalize it
to range between zero and one.
Once normalized.
In this way,
it can be interpreted
as a cumulative distribution
function from probability theory.
This is precisely, in fact precisely
what Sreenivasan, Loughlin and Dubs
did to interpret the firing
of retinal neurons in flies
as a form of predictive coding.
See their Fig. one,
the derivative of the CDF
cumulative distribution function
yields a probability
density function pdf,
so the derivative of a CDF gives a pdf.
This is the more familiar way
of representing
a probability distribution
where the height
on the vertical axis
corresponds to likelihood in the PDF.
But for a pdf derived
from a capacity curve,
it represents relative
responsiveness to perturbation.
We will call such distribution
a reference distribution.
So this is a transformation
of statistical distributions
between the PDF,
which is the probability
density function
and CDF cumulative
distribution function.
It might be very familiar to some,
it might be totally new to some,
so it's all good.
Hopefully this is useful.
Still
to consider the relationship
between the two.
So here
on the left of these three
images, the PDF
which is the more familiar way
of representing
a probability distribution
we would say
this is a uniform distribution.
There's a one in six chance
of getting each outcome from a six
sided die
or in the Gaussian bell curve situation,
which both of these two
middle and right images show.
The PDF of the bell curve
is the Bell Curve.
So the PDF is the most familiar one.
The uniform distribution
is like a flat line in the pdf.
The bell curve is like
the bell curve in the PDF,
but since you know
the maximum and minimum values,
if only asymptotically,
then you can make
a cumulative distribution function
which starts basically
as low as the function can go.
The support for that distribution,
and it just accumulates cumulatively.
So it's useful to answer the question
what is the probability
of getting a four or three or two
or one
that is two thirds
or what is the probability of getting a
Z score of below two
like two standard deviations positive?
What fraction of the curve is below
that z score on the pdf?
And that is addressable by quickly.
Just looking up a point on this CDF,
it turns out that that relationship
between the PDF and the CDF,
which is more familiar to again
like rolling a die
or evaluating like height in a classroom
can be used on the capacity
curve discussed earlier
to move to a distribution
which when maximized, is in this
spot of
maximum control.
So here the CDF from FIG.
two gets the derivative
and then it becomes the PDF
with the sort of negative
curve shape.
And that's kind of
what was being hinted at
with this orange line being maximized
or his line being maximized
is the high point on this
bell curve like
but it's not a classical bell curve,
but it is a mountain.
It's
one peak that you can know
which side you're on
and therefore
pretty easily optimized towards
for analytical convenience.
We take
the practice from Todorov
2006 of using a log density.
The logarithm of a PDF
as an objective function
rather than the PDF itself.
The operating point
then continues to appear
as local maximum,
while the gain determines
the cost of movement away
from the operating point
and the value of movement towards it.
Figure eight shows
the objective function log density
corresponding to the original
barrel reflex capacity curve.
FIG.
nine further clarifies the relationship
between the various
forms of capacity curve
by showing
all three alongside each other.
So this is a really nice figure
on the top
left of the figure is the figure one
with the reflex
that gets dialed up
or dialed down
to regulate blood pressure.
That's when interpreted as the CDF
can result in a PDF
and that is a single peak
that you can maximize.
Instead of trying to calculate
a residual.
The shape of this curve
becomes slightly nicer
to optimize computationally
when you make it
so that it's like a smoother ball
rather than this kind of like inverted
funnel shape, it just
we can go into more detail.
Why? I think that'll be cool.
Why does this log stuff matter
or does it matter?
But suffice to say that
this is the big move
that lets
you turn the sigmoid juggling act
into the mountain, climb
table one
summarizes some key
table one summarizes some key notations
we do not claim our graphical model
accurately captures
the anatomy of the brain.
It captures reference
sensory motor control
across a hierarchy of time
scales, a single feature
shared with the brain
variables in a table
equations five and six
about the instantaneous capture rate.
We'll discuss it in the .1.2.
Section 4.2
also will be nice to discuss.
It is optimal
foraging theory suggests
a functional form
for all static control.
Do you want to add anything up
front about optimal foraging?
No, other than I want to.
I want to talk with the authors about
what does that even mean?
That'll be great.
Write Equation eight Global Capture Rate
Section 4.3
Feedback or Feedforward
Control with Generative Action Concepts.
So here are some more formal isms.
And this is within
not the experimental psychologist
framework,
but rather
the control theoretic framework
with our static capacity
estimate here on the left,
section 4.3,
Equation ten, equation 11
or variables
stochastic optimal control associate,
which was mentioned earlier,
Equation 12, Figure ten
This one will be used to discuss
a hierarchical,
generative model,
capturing multiple timescales
and reference distributions
at each level
without addressing empirical questions
about neural hierarchies.
Here we employ a model
with L equal four models to match FIG.
six.
It defines
what some of these nodes mean, but the
y axis is increasing time scale.
So perhaps slower things higher up.
And then on
the right is the passage of time.
So what does this make
you think about or what is it
like a way we can approach
the interpretation of this?
Well, I'm not trying to be a
smart apple,
but I do find it interesting that floor,
because it
gives you quite a bit of information
that I mean, there's maybe
and they talk about the fact
that there's more than four levels,
but they want to focus on those four.
I mean, where my brain goes is, okay,
so we got the water,
we got the yeast, we got the hops,
we've got the grains.
And that can create quite,
quite the product.
So you can go past that,
you can add juice or whatever,
but you've got the four
basic ingredients.
So now moving to time,
what does that enable?
So again, be nice for them to pull out
all that apart
because I think even in this,
there's enough there
to
figure it.
A lot of stuff out.
Right?
4.4 Feedback Control
with generative action concepts.
Still there is equation 13, Equation 14
and then a nice quote.
Readers are familiar
with predictive processing
and active inference will recognize
the form of the above equation 14
as negative free energy
or variational lower
bound for discussion.
See some citations since the objectives
can typically be written out
and interpreted in several equivalent
ways,
each of which
can come with its own intuitions.
There are arguments
for the computational
and thermodynamic efficiency
of minimizing this specific divergence
in the course of neural processing.
But to date, the available
evidence does not rule out
other, more complex information.
Divergences for penalizing
feedback, correction of movements.
So it's pretty interesting how different
lower bounds
variational lower
bounds, negative free energies
exist like there's expected free energy
and then there's free energy
of the expected future
and there's all of these variance.
And then each of those
energies can be decomposed differently,
like equation 2.6 in the textbook.
So it's
interesting to see how first off,
how did they converge to this kind
of a bound
and from
why should it have such resonance
with free energy principle
and what does that mean?
And then how can different partitioning
of these energy balance
help us think about
systems that survive?
I'll just out here, Danielle,
that we're going to get to these things.
But up to this point in the paper,
guess I had a bit of familiarity
and I didn't really struggle
with the sort of the
lockstep way
that we were going through this.
But then as soon as we got to
Equations 13
and the jump to Equation 50 and, and 16,
somebody,
somebody brighter than me is
going to have to be able
to explain that jump
in real simple terms,
because even though I read it
a number of times, I'm
not exactly sure how it works.
So again, the authors really want to
bring their
their
softest gloves because
I need my handheld.
Yeah, agreed.
Section 4.4.
Still, here's equation 15,
Section 4.4, here's equation 16.
Substituting the augmented objective
fancy j Equation 14
and the analytical expression
for the optimal feedback
controller alone.
Equation 15 into the Belmont Equation.
Equation 12 would yield.
Equation 16 Let's learn what it is.
Yep.
Now the intractable
recursive term in the equation is
etc.
Finding a way to replace
this term will yield
a more computational tractable problem.
The information diversions term in fancy
j provides
just such a way,
since it could be written as precisely
the difference between the intractable
maximum under Q Star Sub Phi
and the more tractable smooth
maximum under the pre-planned action
concept in symbols equation 17.
Pretty interesting.
Okay.
Equation 17 through 21.
Then the final section, section
five discussion.
This is more modified.
Maybe you can help me today.
So were 13 through 17 and
and then 18, 19 and 20 a way
of being able to put together
some of the scale three
formalism with the scale specific
or scale friendly
details and particulars.
When you read this, is that what you
saw them trying to clarify?
That's a great question.
As they talk about global,
and I think they have to be able
to spell that out. And I think it did.
But again, I'm it was all of a sudden
things went off into the ditch for me.
Here's what I would
venture
in the early section.
There's a contrasting of homeostasis
with our spaces
and about how reward systems
are no longer
required under certain
distributed models of brain
neuroanatomy and a function
so I believe that the following
formal isms
substitute the augmented objective
into in optimality
and optimization and framework
like the Bellman equation,
which is often used
for reward maximization.
So I'm rewarded by getting
to the top of the mountain.
So I'm going to evaluate paths
based upon how much reward they accrue,
and then curiosity or so on
will be valuable
to the extent over the time
horizon that I considered.
It facilitates reward
in terms of elevation,
whereas we
here are
seeing the move towards
that like
optimal maneuverability maximization
with pdf CDF relationship
like instead of trying
to reduce divergence
to the midpoint of the CDF
where you maximize your responsiveness
in terms of maximizing the log pdf.
Okay.
So I think that's the augmented
reward function
which is tractable.
And then some work remains
to specify that function
and how it behaves.
Perhaps
what.
Then?
Section five
discussion interception
stabilizes action and constructs
all static references.
People can look at the quotes.
Anything to summarize here?
No. All right.
5.1 Viewing
the brain
as an allosteric optimal controller,
the allosteric path integral control
APC model
in Section
four implies
a number of specific hypotheses
beyond those generic
to stochastic optimal control.
There's some discussion
of shared modeling choices
with active inference
models, perhaps enough for APC
to be considered
an active inference model of sorts,
and then
a few other
features that are shared
with active inference models
in strict sense, if one even exists,
and also related
modeling efforts, anything to add.
Know how to spell it out
pretty clearly here.
You just want to read through this.
All right.
5.1, provide some predictions
and some contrasts with APC model
5.2,
the body in the brain
through the lens of control theory.
Figure six
show how visceral sense data is
and in effect to become ex
afferent intercept of prediction errors.
Do you want to explain
briefly what an x afferent means?
Because people wait.
They do explain that
in the glossary, but
it's basically an accurate
signal on an accuracy.
Lose a bit a recursion there.
You want to add anything to that?
I
see the distinction
just to highlight what afferent is.
Afferent is conducting
or conducted inwards
or towards something for the nerves.
The central nervous system
for blood vessels,
the organ supplied right.
And
how you distinguish exact it's.
Just it's just that it's sort of
cumulative.
It's not it's not sort of the
the initial
is what I took away from that
the accumulation of those signals.
Interesting
I like your on that's what I took.
Five three interception and capacity
curves
theories of peripheral predictive coding
reason that a neurons
most metabolically
cheap responses should represent
the predictable stimuli, whereas
expensive responses are reserved
for the most surprising stimuli.
Some predictions and suggestions
from BERRETT 2017
and findings of two work in 2013.
Certain peripheral interceptors
in humans
reduce their afferent firing
rate to zero under a constant stimulus.
So that's kind of interesting.
Like if no change, don't tell me
about it.
And that should be cheap.
Under a model
where something is changing.
Less often than not, it's
and there's some more
hypotheses
we have hypothesized that increases
in such responsiveness,
which is the imperative in this APC
model
could function as rewards
positively reinforcing
behavioral trajectories,
while decreases in responsiveness
could function as costs
negatively reinforcing
behavioral trajectories.
So keeping options open
over the infinite time horizon
becomes equivalent
to keeping the business
floating or keeping physiology bounded.
Yep.
Continuity instead of just maximizing
amount of USD or calories.
Right.
But rather having reduced
or bounded surprises
or about a range
and a trajectory and a strategy.
Not in this model as stated here,
to generate that
pathway.
Three Interception and capacity
curves more 5.4 Conclusions.
Finally, we return to the amateur
dodgeball player.
We aren't mature.
Yet
and some summarization
of the epic model
and suggestions
about its compatibility
with the referent control hypothesis
and some of its tractability.
That's the discussion.
Then Appendix B Judiciary,
which we've talked about before,
but it's kind of a cool topic.
So just to skip
through these appendices,
just discussing them with the authors,
we hope then
some more equations in equation
B formulating perception
and control ergodic
LIH leads to the free energy
principle FSB
More of Appendix B Appendix C
Aps-C Model Derivation Details
Equations
See point one.
Point two Full derivation
of optimal value function
and transition dynamics.
More Equations
The path integral
form for the value
desirability function gives its name
to the technique
of path integral control.
And so a kind of closing note,
we wondered how
this connects to the Bayesian mechanics
and to the path formulation, the right?
Most of the three
phases of Bayesian mechanics
and about how coming
potentially from quite a different
starting point and with different
approaches and constraints,
some similar features
might have
arisen and been highlighted in APAC
that are also highlighted
and relevant for Bayesian mechanics
in the PATH Formalization.
And maybe there's like
a kind of unmapped Venn diagram there
and some similarities and differences.
The proximity to the last live stream,
whether by accident or by intent,
makes the way that you look
at this paper
interesting.
I'll just say.
Yeah, agreed.
Well,
anything you want to
close with?
I think the idea of being able
to look at a model
and modeling
internal modeling
and sort of the coordination of that,
either either again, kind of
as a minimum to other as risk management
or risk
minimizing exercise,
therefore limiting strategy
or as an option generating
or an expanding strategy
would be
something really interesting
to talk to the authors about,
because, again, I can't
I can't really figure out
whether or not
the APIC model works in both domains.
Do I get past
the jump between formalism 13
and all the way up to 17, 18, 19 and 21?
I mean, with an explanation of that
and and
and then a gentle prod,
it'd be interesting to find out how
how that works
when those things seem to be, be it
we as physiological entities
are able to juggle
both the risk management and the option
and option generator option, expanding.
So I am really actually quite
excited about that. From a
here's what I'm feeling.
How should I read that
in terms of what I can, how far out
I can make my next bet
from analysis, static perspective,
I think that's really exciting.
If you get yeah,
like I said,
if I can get
a better sense of how that jump
works in their model.
Yeah,
definitely interested
in that infinite time horizon
and that mentality of like
what's the best physiological
decision over the infinite
horizon, right?
That's a great question.
And yeah, the eternal now the presence
and then also a little bit more mundane,
like what kind of data
are relevant for this type of model?
Is it data that already exists for
people or is it something
where you can extrapolate
a lot from a sparse data set?
Or do you need a bunch of
replication
to get good statistical confidence
on the model parameter
and extract
findings that are like non-trivial?
And.
Whereas, this
technology or approach
being used or where could it be
used, there's like a lot of things
that'll be interesting to talk about.
Well,
thank you for all the preparation
and help on this one
Dean and see you in
the don't want to be aren't.
My friend take care.
Bye.